このたびは
私
肇社長に関する
一連の騒動について
お話ししたいと思います
ただいま
沢山の
事実である情報
そして
事実とは異なる情報が
ネット上に出回っておりますが
この件に関しまして
大勢の視聴者の皆様
そして
関係者の皆様を
お騒がせしてしまい
誠に申し訳ございませんでした
今回は
その件について
お話しさせていただきたいと思います
ただいま
ネット上で言われている情報が
大きく分けて
3つでございます
一つ目は
私が以前
お付き合いさせていただいていた女性についてです
二つ目は
その以前お付き合いさせていただいた女性との交際期間中に
他の女性と
関係を持っていたという情報
3つ目は
以前
お付き合いさせていただいていた女性との交際期間な
それ以前に付き合っていた女性との交際期間がかぶっていた
という間についてです
まず一つ目です
私が以前
お付き合いさせていただいていた女性についてお話しさせていただきます
現在
その女性が
渡すと以前
付き合っていたときにあった
内容や画像
line の像方など
ネット上に公開し
その内容が真実かどうかという疑惑が
発生しておりますが
この件に関しまして
その女性と私が以前お付き合いしていたことは
事実でございます
一つ目は
その
女性の証言の中に
交際期間汁に私が
他の女性と
関係を持っていた
という発言に関しまして
こちらから
お話ししたいことがございます
細かい内容をお話しさせていただきますと
2月の中4日
私の誕生日に
以前
お付き合いさせていただいていた女性に
14feb の予定はあえていないか
というお話をいただいたところ
私の方では
すでに
有人島の予定8
どんな撮影
編集などはあり
当日は会えない
という返信をしたにも関わらず
当日に
他の女性を家に泊めていた
といった内容のものですこちらの件に関しましては
先に
事実を述べさせていただきますと
2月中4日多忙だったために
予定を入れられなかったものの
その後
二月十五日の
午前3時頃に
友人の女性が
私の家に来て
泊まりに来ていたことは
事実でございます
この像方が
どこからリークしたかと言いますと
私本人が
以前
お付き合いしていた女性に
お話ししたために
彼女本人からん
象方が出回っております
実際に
その時自宅に来ていた女性は
私とは友人関係であり
友人としての付き合いが短いわけでもなく
信頼のできる友人である
時間的にも変えることができなかったために
その女性が止まって言っても
何も問題はないと
私が判断いたしました
こちらとしては
ゆうしんだったらねぇ
当時付き合っていた彼女に
次女彼のことを聞かれたタイミングで
やましいことは一切していないのでん
直接お話ししました事実を話させていただきますと
その女性とは
一切そう言って関係はなく
現在
付き合っているという事実もございません
ただ
当時付き合っていた女性の見方からすると
その女性と
関係を持っていると勘違いされても
仕方のない
私の甘い判断だったと思っております
3つ目は
私が以前
付き合っていた女性との交際期間が
それ以前に
付き合っていた女性との交際期間に
かぶっていたということについてです
この件に関しましては
事実でございます
私が以前
付き合っていた女性とお付き合いをする前に
その以前にお付き合いしていた女性に別れを切り出していたのですか
お互いな忙しさや
意見が食い違いなどにより話がまとまらず
交際期間が
かぶってしまったという時間がありました
その期間に関しましては
私の
未熟な判断により
双方の女性に
不快な思いをさせてしまったことを
大変
申し訳なく思っております
このたびは
大勢の方に
大変なご心配をおかけしてしまう
まことに
申し訳ございませんでした